yo theo vaughn this is luke from down
here in baton rouge man
um what's up luke from baton rouge
and luke is usually from the bible but i
see you kind of taking a detour
onward brother i'm a big fan big fan uh
actually i saw you down in new orleans
at the house of blues once it was a good
great show actually uh but look
thank you man it's nicey to say that man
it really is and
yes you know it used to be that we could
be out there doing it
and doing the rigmarole and and doing
the live show and now
um it's a little different now but we're
here
together right now and that's what's
important and that's what's unique about
this
loop is that you and i were together
there and he'll be back here together
man
and that's something if you think about
something
that could be it onward look man i got a
little question uh my brother's getting
married in a couple of weeks and uh
i've got i'm his best man of course i
know uh
dad you were actually your brother's
best man
i've got to give uh you know a toast to
him of course
interesting man obviously luke is a
stalker as well but now we apprec uh
yeah i was the best man at my brother's
wedding
was i the best man oh jesus
dude my brother's gonna freaking hate me
dude
i mean my brother's my best man i know
that
you know i never i uh
i don't know jeep jeeps jeeps uh anyway
enough about me onward luke i wanna hear
more from you man
dad you were actually your brother's
best man
i've gotta give uh you know a toast to
him of course and
i um i'm an emotional person i don't
know how emotional i should get with
with the toast and you know what not so
i figured i'd ask if you had some
pointers since you had
had been there before being the best man
for your brother
you have any advice for that uh let me
know man uh
also i hope all is well show's great
love listen
to it tell all my friends about it and
everything man
gang gang take care buddy gang gang baby
thanks luke
how sweet of you man for the message and
um
wow you know that's a good question
what do we do for our brothers
you know it's funny if i gave my brother
a best man speech now
as opposed to whenever i did apparently
and i do
this is embarrassing man
i i it just goes to show how much i'm
just stuck in my own head thinking about
myself i can't even remember
i remember i actually you know what i
remember playing in my brother's
bachelor party almost killed us in a
12-pass van
um we had non-alcoholic jello shots
there's a lot of things i do remember
uh it was a beautiful wedding
but i don't um i don't remember having
to give us
best man speech though
did we do jesus oh my god dude i think
my brother listens to this
oh anyway luke enough about me man um
that's a good question
it you know i think
first of all i would keep it
semi-concise i wouldn't go over two
minutes
i think two minutes is about as long as
you kind of want to go
but of course obviously i don't know man
you know if you have a if you have a
suggestion for luke you can hit the
hotline
we'll uh we'll circle back up with some
of these next week
nine eight five six six four nine five
zero three
um how do you what's the best way to do
a best man speech
what's the best way to you know i think
you want to
i think talking about a certain moment
in your life when
whatever your brother did
or said or what a behavior of his
story of my life man trying to have a
feeling and i get an email
i would i would find a you know a time
when your brother did had a behavior or
an action or said something that
resonated with you and just stuck with
you
you know just you can even just specify
on one moment when he just really when
he was a brother
you know a brother is a lot of things i
think it's really selfless and i think
it's um
a good brother anyway and it's
uh you know it's loving is caring is
sacrificial
and it's hard it's hard to be sometimes
an older brother it's hard to be a
younger brother i mean i think a lot of
that could go into
you know but depending on where you are
in the brother chain but
um that's a good question if you have
some suggestions for luke you can hit
the hotline
again 985 66 nine five zero three
uh sometimes i forget it uh but yeah
you know i think just
iterating something that they a moment
that they've done where they really
showed you they cared about you
or really you know
and just let them know how much you care
you know let them just let i think it's
a good time really
yeah you're kind of wishing him best of
luck in his marriage but it's also a
moment where you get to let your brother
know how you feel about him in a public
way without
you know being homosexual or without
being uh
you know without name calling or
anything you get to really just be
loving so
and you can start off with a joke you
know you could say you know
i want to you know i'm so happy
you know i got my brother here if he
even is my brother
and then call out your mom say you know
if he even is my brother diane
because we all know you've done some
things
and just let that sit for about another
second or two and that'll do that'll
really cook up some humor
uh and it could i mean who knows i don't
know what your mother is like but it
could also cause some controversy but
or it could you know you know dig up
some old stuff but um
yeah that's a great question man and
we'll we'll put out that out to the
listeners and we'll do a
response back to you on the next episode
good evening good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one
ah